what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and thor love and
thunder has officially broken the
trailer release date record for least
amount of days between the teaser
trailer releasing and the actual movie
releasing in theaters i think most of
you know exactly what this means but of
course i'll talk about it in this video
and they did release a new promotional
banner for thor love and thunder today
so promotions are kicking up but we
still don't have that trailer when can
we expect it and even though thor love
and thunder now has this new record are
they going to make it harder for other
movies to beat and keep going let's go
ahead and talk about all of this and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news now marvel is
running full steam ahead with all of
their projects coming in 2022 and 2023
we kicked off with moon knight the first
two episodes have been awesome and in
less than a month now doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness is going to
premiere then of course we'll get thor
love and thunder and black panther
wakanda forever but we'll also get the
disney plush shows in between miss
marvel which is going to be coming out
in june we also have she-hulk we also
have what if season 2 and the guardians
of the galaxy holiday special and
possibly werewolf by night this october
so a lot of things happening right now
but thor love and thunder is kind of
right around the corner and we still
don't have that first teaser trailer for
it and it just broke the record for
least amount of days between the teaser
trailers release and the movie's release
now i think most people who have been
following know that the record was held
by the incredible hulk and yes i am
talking about the 2008 film the
incredible hulk it previously held the
record for least amount of days between
the trailer and the release at 93 days
and just to give you an example we all
thought we waited a really long time to
get the trailer for spider-man no way
home but it didn't hold the record there
was actually 116 days between its teaser
trailer and the official movie's release
which is still not a lot of days in
between but thor love and thunder has
broken that record as i talk right now
in this video it is april 7th and there
are 92 days left until thor love and
thunder's july 8th 2022 release date now
i know a lot of people are concerned
that thor love and thunder might get
delayed sure because the trailer isn't
here yet i understand it's kind of a
concern for myself as well but they have
started the press tour for it they have
started promotions for it the trailer
should be right around the corner i'm
not really worried about them delaying
the film i don't think they would have
started with the press tour already if
they were worried that the film was
going to get delayed and yes they were
doing reshoots and they might need some
of that footage to release the trailer
but i still don't think this means the
movie is going to get delayed they work
on movies a lot of the times right up
until the movies are actually released
and marvel studios is kind of known for
doing this they put a lot of work a lot
of time a lot of effort into editing
their movies and making sure they're
fantastic and it shows in the quality of
the movies so i wouldn't be too
concerned about thor love and thunder
getting delayed yet but of course the
question is when are we getting this
trailer well if you've followed my
channel for a while you know that i have
a couple of trailer sources but they
usually tell me when a trailer is a few
days away from coming out not when it's
like a couple of weeks or anything like
that so i don't think it's coming out
this week otherwise i think i would have
heard about it but since the press tour
has started since new promotions are
coming out i'm pretty hopeful for next
week if not hopefully the week after
that because at that point in time the
record for days between the release of
the trailer and the official movie is
going to be in the 80s and it's weird to
think that there's gonna only be a
couple of months and some change in
between this official trailer release
teaser trailer i might add not even an
official full trailer and the movie's
theatrical release that's pretty crazy
as it is right now but like i said a new
promotional banner for thor love and
thunder has also been released today and
we get a better look at thor's new
outfit and a little bit of a better look
at jane foster's new thor outfit as well
and as you can see she's holding mjolnir
it has been broken and mended you can
see all the cracks in it and of course
thor has stormbreaker and i might add we
haven't really heard anything about how
thor is going to get in shape again
because the last time we saw him he was
bro thor i'm really hoping we have
somewhat of a workout montage a funny
workout montage in the beginning of thor
love and thunder to watch him get back
in shape and here we get a good look at
his new gold and blue outfit which seems
to be a little bit of a modern twist on
his comic gold and blue outfit and
hopefully he'll rock his helmet with
wings because as we can see here jane
foster is wearing a helmet with wings
just like her character does in the
comics so hopefully we see thor get to
do that as well and credits to disney
disneyfile.fr for finding this banner so
that's it for the thor love and thunder
news today it has officially broken the
record for at least the amount of days
between the teaser trailers release and
the movie's release and again hopefully
we get that pretty soon but let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below sorry for the short
videos i'm still feeling kind of sick
but still don't forget to subscribe if
you want to stay up to date on all the
latest marvel news don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
[Music]